[Music]
u.s president joe biden set out to
reassure nato leaders of washington's
commitment to the alliance
as he arrived for his first summit of
the 30-member group in brussels
i want to make it clear nato is
critically important
for u.s interests in and of itself if
there weren't one we'd have to invent
one
clearly enjoying the moment biden sought
to rebuild trust after four years of
donald trump
the former u.s leader was openly hostile
to nato
once even threatening to pull out the
military withdrawal from afghanistan
climate change and nato's future were on
the agenda
but relations with russia and china
dominated discussions
china's growing influence and
international policies presents
challenges
to alliance security joe biden succeeded
in persuading nato
to back his administration's push for a
tougher approach to china regarded by
washington
as a major economic and strategic rival
but for most nato allies russia remains
the main threat
relations between moscow and nato are at
their lowest point since the cold war
on wednesday biden is scheduled to meet
russian leader vladimir putin
for highly anticipated talks in geneva i
shared with our allies that i'll convey
to pres what i'll convey to president
putin
that i'm not looking for conflict with
russia but that we will respond if
russia continues its harmful activities
ties with turkey are also tense but
biden called a meeting with the turkish
president productive
the u.s may be back as a reliable nato
partner but this analyst says some
allies have concerns
the allies here as in asia
will remember that trump had happened
that something like him could happen
again in the future
there are divisions in nato on some
issues but those differences remained
mainly behind closed doors
as biden took center stage leaders were
clearly determined to turn a diplomatic
page
and show a united front natasha butler
al-jazeera brussels
well for more on nato's criticism of
china let's speak to benjamin herzkowitz
who's a research fellow at the school of
regulation and global governance at the
australian national university
is joining us from sydney thank you very
much for being with us mr herzkowitz
now while it's not unusual to hear
criticism of russia and nato it is
surprising somewhat to hear beijing
being mentioned
and making an appearance in the
alliance's final joint
statement for the first time what do you
make of this and how will beijing be
viewing this
thank you very much it's great to be
with you look it is a significant
development and it
comes as part of this broader effort on
the part of the vitamin administration
to take a much more multinational
multilateralized approach to
ramping up its effort to combat china's
power and china's influence
globally and it's a function of the fact
that
the biden administration has made all of
these very positive overtures to europe
and has demonstrated that it's willing
to put relationships with
european countries on a totally new
trajectory
in comparison to the quiet adversarial
testy hostile relationship that the
trump administration had with nato and
with a range of european countries
so the united states is fully going down
this route of great power competition
with china and is really
marshalling european support and nato
support for that effort
right in terms of the view for beijing
beijing would be viewing this with
a great deal of concern not because of
the substance of it it is
effectively a diplomatic signal but
because of the way in which it
demonstrates that
the byte administration is already
successfully
marshaling a coalition of countries
which it's seeking to
bring on board with its efforts to
combat china's power and influence is it
though i mean while relations between
the us and china are clearly defined
european leaders i imagine have to
thread more carefully
when it comes to china i think that's
absolutely correct and it's important to
approach this statement from nato with
a certain amount of critical skepticism
on the one hand
it is a significant diplomatic
development in that nato is leaning into
this kind of language visiting china
but you're absolutely correct that there
are very different
views of china in washington versus
in paris or berlin or london the united
states under the biden administration
has fully embraced great power
competition with china and is seeking to
maintain
u.s global leadership effectively in a
range of arenas whether that be
in the technological arena or the
military arena whereas for
european countries they have serious
concerns about beijing's aspirations and
the way
beijing is using its newfound power that
they do not see
us leadership as a good in and of itself
so
even though on the surface it looks like
there's a significant alignment of
european and u.s interests in actual
fact that probably
papers over a significant disagreement
between
what the long-term goal of this is for
europeans
the hope is that china will reign in a
little bit its ambitions
and be a bit more cooperative on the
world stage and be
a bit more of a collaborative
multilateral player
first for the united states the goal is
to maintain unrivaled u.s leadership and
european view does not lend itself to
fully supporting that us goal
yeah and we also heard criticism of
china at the g7 g7 leaders uh
criticizing china's human rights record
uh in xinjiang uh to which we we saw a
response from the chinese embassy in
london a strongly worded statement
um and and the g7 summit g7 leaders were
also talking about setting up an
alternative to the
uh belton road infrastructure initiative
that beijing's launch what sort of
response do you think we can anticipate
from china
and do you see a significant shift of
china's foreign policy as a result of
this
what appears to be anyway this widening
divide
with the americans and now possibly also
the europeans
i that there won't be a significant
shift
in responsive developments in terms of
china's foreign policy
the view from beijing is that countries
like the united states
and a range of european countries are
already deeply adversarial
to some of china's core interests and in
particular
beijing's efforts to shape its internal
policies as it sees fit it sees european
countries and it sees the united states
as
interfering in its internal affairs and
these latest developments
will make no changes to that china will
still see these other countries of
meddling in its internal affairs
in terms of the belt and road initiative
and chinese investments abroad
i suspect that beijing already
understood that european countries and
the united states were broadly skeptical
of the belgian road
and broadly skeptical of chinese
infrastructure investments and so
beijing will seek to push forward with
that goal of
building influence of building friends
in particular in southeast asia in south
asia and in africa
and initiatives from european countries
or from the united states probably won't
change that ultimately
but it will however solidify in
beijing's mind
the notion that the united states and
increasingly european countries
are seeking to undermine some of what
china considers to be its core interests
okay let's leave it there thank you so
much for for talking to us thank you for
your insight benjamin hirschkovic from
the australian national university